[Music]
well just as soon as he kisses her
then
[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
hey good morning mug club
my name is audio wade hey how's it going
everybody i know it's not steven sitting
here which is
confusing at least but we do have steven
he's going to be here
he is headed right now to a change my
mind on the topic of amy coney bear it's
going to be fill the seat
change my mind it's gonna be an exciting
day in studio here is brendan
on the tricaster can you see brendan
there we go hey there's brendan
well this is exciting what a happy day
all right so yeah so we will be
taking your chats today only on the
blaze so we do have uh we know that
there are facebook chats we're not going
to take any
from youtube anything like that because
again they don't don't pay they don't
pay us nothing i think is the
way steven describes it so yeah we'll be
doing that um yeah so
again br get your chats in uh on blaze
tv
head over now i think um let's see we do
have steven on the line can we see you
stephen
yes i can see can you guys uh can you
guys hear me well we can hear you well
yeah you're sitting over there in your
car so you are headed now to who told
you you could sit in my
ex chair and by the looks of your your
uh
nerves here leave a little oh henry bar
on there
when i get back i thought you were gonna
be doing it from your booth your
audience oh
well maybe i guess i just uh made a bad
assumption
that's my fault yeah sorry about that mr
crowder yes it doesn't harm me so much
as it does the viewers
that's true so i uh so we're sitting
here in the studio the b
team i guess but you are headed to a
change my mind
on the topic of amy coney barrett big
story in the news right now confirmation
hearings i guess are going on right now
yeah so what do you expect to see in the
change my mind you know what's uh what's
going on today
well first off yeah everyone who's in
the chat of course is a member of mug
club uh please do send what what you
want to see
discussed most or what you expect people
to uh discuss most and uh
one of the we'll be doing a couple of
different locations today so i know this
is the first time we've done this it's a
bit on the fly um
one will be on campus where i think i've
been banned but we're kind of off
campus but on campus and then we'll be
moving around uh uh
somewhere else around town uh so we get
uh
kind of a varied response this is one of
those things where
i just don't see and often this is when
it comes up when uh i change my mind
sort of comes
it stems from exhaustion sometimes i
just don't see any valid argument
as to uh why we don't confirm this
thing i really don't like
constitutionally
as far as precedent decorum there's
nothing to say that we shouldn't other
than some people don't like her opinions
and listen i understand that
i didn't like uh sotomayor's opinions i
didn't like kagan's opinions but that
was that's the process right if you have
uh a president who nominates and you
have a senate that confirms
them is the breaks so i i expect people
to
sit down and probably say well they
think it's wrong they think it's
underhanded
a lot of them probably don't know that
this has happened 29 times in american
history
uh a lot of them probably don't know
that this is right in line with with
both precedence and precedent
um and uh i bet you a lot of them don't
know a whole lot about amy coney barrett
outside of what the media has told them
so i'm hoping this will coincide nicely
with
the grilling and the anti-christian
anti-catholic
sentiment that will be taking place
today during the hearings and and
hopefully uh
simultaneously be able to be broadcast
and inform some people and listen
people need to know too if we get enough
and this always depends because it
changed my mind
you know sometimes we'll have people sit
down and they go well i don't know i
think she's a [ __ ] like okay thank you
for sitting down
you know we just don't broadcast but
pretty much everyone always sees
every change my mind that we record
unless it's someone who
seems like they might be challenged or
will have sometimes people just show up
to promote their own stuff like hey i'm
running for the 42nd congressional
district
now provided that those don't happen if
we get enough um
we're going to be running change my
minds on amy coney barrett
for two whole days so we'll be running
it tomorrow morning
and then wednesday morning and and of
course uh live fact checking
the biden town hall on thursday so it's
it's it's a jam-packed week
um but yeah that was a roundabout way i
kind of got everything in there but yeah
that's what i expect i don't know
and i try to go in open-minded with
these things it's not a debate it really
is
i'm hoping that i hear something that
gives me a light bulb moment as to why
these
folks are against nominating her and i
haven't heard anything other than well
we don't like her
merrick garland yeah yeah absolutely so
and i i we do have a chat here from
christopher christopher says
what is your take on the dems
threatening to increase the number of
seats
in the supreme court do you expect that
to come up today or you know what are
your general thoughts on that
i do expect that to come up today and
that was that's a tough one
the court packing uh because first off
we have changed the number of seats it's
very between five and ten
but that was a very different time that
was during the founding of the country
when they actually hadn't
really created most of the circuit
courts sure um
and so they didn't really know how many
representatives they needed uh
and then abraham lincoln uh you know had
uh 10 uh justices uh
as he was going into slavery right and
that was that was a civil war the last
time this happened
was a civil war over 150 years ago
it has been nine ever since and i tell
you what if we're going to be talking
about honoring ruth bader ginsburg's uh
dying wishes which no one can confirm
and her granddaughter just says is true
uh how about honoring her actually uh
written on the record opinions and she
was
vehemently against court packing for the
same reason that uh
joe biden was vehemently against court
packing up until literally three weeks
ago
yeah it is crazy how quickly that's
changed so we do and another chat here
from
jonas he says discuss the difference
between merrick garland
his name is jonas that's true it is
jonas
carrying the show that's not very nice
uh the uh discuss the difference between
merrick garland and amy coney barrett
so yeah i obviously expect that to come
out because that was that was
essentially the argument that you heard
about
yeah it's ridiculous here's what i will
say this to me is one of the most
beautiful examples
of the three branches of government
anyone out there watch the schoolhouse
rock
you guys remember it's executive
legislative
judiciary right these are the three
branches of government that we have the
judiciary is meant to be
the most separate and apart so for
someone to be confirmed
right to the judiciary that's that third
branch it has to go through
the executive the president has to
nominate and then it has to go through
the legislative where you then have the
senate who has to confirm
and then we have a new justice on the
judiciary
hey there's a thought merrick garland we
had executive barack obama nominated
just as 29 times with presidents who
have come before him
and uh we had a senate who rejected and
in this case
we have republican senate so they'll
likely confirm barack obama was well in
his authority to nominate
just as the senate was well and their
well in their authority to deny
donald trump is well within his
authority to nominate authority to
nominate just as barack obama was
and the senate is well within its
authority to deny or accept
nothing has changed i don't understand
why it's an issue so it's one of those
things people say merrick garland
merrick garland well the issue wasn't
just that it was an election year that's
what the media tried to paint it out to
be because
obviously they cherry-picked the
arguments that you heard presented from
lindsey graham or mcconnell lindsey
graham said
uh on the record several times he said
listen this is unprecedented in a split
election
in a split party right now between the
executive branch sure the legislative
blanche in
an election year to expect it to get
forced through that's just not going to
happen
and then of course when he goes on the
cable news shows and he talks more
sometimes he doesn't express in the full
breadth of his argument and says well
this is an election year it's different
so then people take the weakest argument
right the left and they go oh
all he said was it was the election year
that's not he was very clear in what he
was expressing
conservatives who knew what they were
talking about knew i was an issue now
my concern here and this is why we did
the change in mind is i do see
unfortunately a lot of people on the
right
who um were reductive who simplified it
too
it's an election year well that was
never the argument it was never my
argument
sure so uh hopefully this provides an
opportunity to um
illuminate that for example because it
wasn't just about it being an election
year it was about it being a divided
government and by the way
in midterms republicans have only added
seats to the senate
so when people say oh it's a vote of no
conflict well no in this case it's a
vote of
supreme confidence when you're talking
about the senate yeah absolutely
yeah and we have another one here
actually about the i changed my mind i
guess in general it says
in it's from stephen with a ph uh in
today's in today's cultural climate that
guy gets
martyred wow uh in today's cultural
climate
is it possible ah delightful
in today's cultural climate is it
possible to help someone change their
mind or
are people doomed to be stuck in their
ways
what do you think i mean obviously
you're going out there doing something
called change my mind
it assumes that there's at some level
some ability for people to
change their minds today right um
well i'll tell you what i've never had
my mind changed entirely on an issue or
fundamentally on an issue
uh and i changed my mind but i have had
my mind open on certain thoughts and i
will say this
in trying to change my mind often people
change their own mind often people end
up finding common ground so
uh to stephen with a ph hopefully you've
watched change my mind before and if you
have you've seen dozens of examples of
other people changing their minds
simply through the attempt uh to change
their mind and that's that's
all that also can't happen by the way
when there's a debate
when it's just a debate where you're
trying to score points which is what we
have on television which is what the
cable news system is designed to
encourage
uh you've got an eight minute segment
and you've got to use up as much time as
possible to score points right because
your only job at that point
is to try and show the audience right
the dwindling audience with cable news
how your arguments are supreme when it
changed my mind it's almost like uh
you know you've been doing jiu jitsu
more now and you've sort of grown to
understand the difference
that simply having rounds makes right
ufc's
they had no rounds they had no time
limit
and when that's the case guess what you
didn't have anyone stalling
and then looking to score points before
the end of the round for the
ref to step in you didn't have anyone
looking to the ref because there was no
ref
that's what changed my mind is it's
listen it's it's a slow cook
it's we sit down there is no ref there
is no one keep in time
there is no one who needs to get to uh
reverse mortgage commercials
it is do the ideas stand or fall and of
course we're not going to be talking for
two
three hours because sometimes these
people like to be long-winded
there is a point where you have to end
it when you realize it's no longer
fruitful
but that really is um what changed my
mind
is i i've tried to reiterate this as
often as possible it is not a debate
people can go and watch what a debate is
like when i was on bbc
or sky news or fox news or russia today
or we've had people on our show i'm very
clear that it's different when there's a
debate
no this is trying to encourage people to
rationalize their position
and use a socratic method and often
people have never done that and
specifically on college campuses which
is remarkable because a lot of these
kids who come up
are and not just kids we've done it
obviously downtown austin we've done it
downtown dallas we've done it in front
of the white house we've done it in
michigan right we've done it in vermont
not always at schools but what is most
remarkable to me is when we
do these kinds of events at schools is
uh you'll have people who come up who
are studying philosophy or humanities
and they've never used the socratic
method as clear as they
yeah that's insane yeah i think probably
a lot of what you'll encounter today is
going to be
you know maybe some some of the
anti-christian or anti-catholic kind of
sentiment we have a
question here from mark who says so why
is acb
being crucified for being catholic but
not but joe biden isn't
that's because joe biden isn't catholic
okay
what do you mean what do you mean by
that i mean this is a guy who wants uh
millions of unborn babies killed in
their mother's womb
and uh uh uh i mean his best uh he's
buddied up with the lady who's been
denied communion i don't
listen you'll know them by the fruits of
the tree i don't know anything about joe
biden i don't know any values that he
has expressed that are catholic values
none so but i don't then again i also
feel that way about the pope
um i'm not a catholic i'm a protestant i
know we have plenty of brothers and
sisters in the in the
uh the catholic denomination where we
disagree on theology but i think we find
of course a lot of common ground and and
one of them that really seems to be
undeniable should be the idea of life
yeah and uh joe biden doesn't believe
that his running mates don't believe
that and
joe biden at every turn if you can look
at uh what he's espoused and what he's
believed
it uh it runs in diametric opposition to
the catholic church now it's it's
something that
i can't say he's not a catholic i can
say he's not an observant catholic
for the same same reason that ben
shapiro was jewish
okay harvey weinstein is jewish you
think they're going to this
you think they're going to the same
synagogue i mean like you think they're
no listen
this is important to know so the only
way to really determine it would be to
ask joe biden
not how does your catholic faith inform
you it would be like hey
do you believe that jesus christ died on
the cross for your sins and is the one
and only way to get through heaven
and if he says no he's not a catholic ah
amy coney barrett's been asked that
she's answered very quick clearly
unequivocally i've never heard joe biden
answer that way
right yeah and for some reason it isn't
seen as a an impediment to joe biden
being able to make decisions but it is
seen as an impediment for acb to be seen
as an impediment because people don't
believe that his catholicism means
anything
let's be if they believed that he was
actually catholic they know that joe
biden would be pro-life and he would not
be the democratic nominee
if they believed that he was actually
catholic he would have a deep sympathy
for the founding fathers in the
constitution
and the reasons that we have the framing
for this country that we do
and he would be out there espousing his
catholic views and he would be praising
acb for catholicism
and for her uh for her faith for her
adoption of
children from uh craphole countries uh
and i say that because it's a good thing
that they were rescued
they don't they're not concerned with it
for the same reason that they weren't
concerned with barack obama's
christianity for the same reason that
barack obama never seen it we've never
seen it in a church
directed his entire presidency sure
because they know that they don't mean
it
right yeah that makes sense yeah so we
have another chat here from
brett uh he says do you think it's time
to change lifetime appointments for the
supreme court
obviously that's the current system but
what do you think uh no
no okay not right now
yeah i guess i mean listen that's a
topic i set you up with a yes or no
question that's my fault
no no it's okay if it's a yes or no
question right now no
um and certainly not as they're
discussing packing chords
i think we need to deal with amy coney
barrett and then we need to deal with
this idea of packing courts in the
election before we get to the idea of
lifetime appointments
do i see a valid argument uh to be
against it long term
sure i absolutely do um for the same
reason that i see a valid argument
against uh
against serious term limits for um you
know uh
local representatives sure um but uh
right now that's not a discussion that i
think needs to be on the table what
needs to be on the table is is getting
this
this the distinguished uh lady confirmed
and uh making sure that everyone knows
court packing is straight from the pit
of hell
gotcha yeah so and one of the things
that i guess the right has been able to
laugh off
but i i guess is a serious argument on
the left somebody said here so
i would like to see uh amber says i
would like to see you discuss how racist
acb is for stealing those poor haitian
children and then erasing their real
parents
you mentioned that i guess uh sort of
offhand but i mean do you expect that to
come up is anybody
actually arguing that or is that just
something that you know the right is
able to make fun of
uh you know i she says i would like to
see you discuss
i'm not going to discuss it unless
someone brings it up it's not an article
right
if someone brings it up i'll just say oh
okay
yeah it's one of those things like why i
think that conservatives unfortunately
in amber i appreciate it but i think
that a lot of people who maybe come from
uh there was a sort of new wave of
people who came from not that they were
alt-right but that's where a lot of
people sort of came in this trolling
idea it doesn't mean that it's the best
thing to do it may be fun on twitter to
make fun of people but if you're
actually having a discussion here
and the idea is to change people's minds
i certainly won't veer the conversation
into what do you think you know like
baiting that
shirt in that hook kind of like a bait
when you reach for my foot and i put you
in a crucifix when we're doing jiu jitsu
i'm like oh what's this foot doing here
you're like i've got a single leg oh i'm
being choked
i'm not going to try and bait out there
like what do you think about adopting
black kids
because it's just a fruitless endeavor
the only place that argument goes is
well i think it's racist and i say well
i think it's wonderful
i mean what else sure it's just you
think it's racist do you think it's
horrible that
she adopted children and brought them
into a loving home from a
horrible poverty stricken land
uh often in many cases i don't know her
exact scenario without parents to begin
with or parents who certainly don't want
them
you think it's wrong because you see
everything through the prism of race
i think it's wonderful because i see it
through the prism of
love that is defined by my christian
faith which will piss people off because
you know what matters to me
yeah well you've talked about how there
are there is a difference between
someone
that you can change their mind and
someone that you might just use as like
an example to say like okay well we just
have fundamentally different
views of the world and i guess that
that's sort of what changed my mind is
able to sort those
different people out yeah with the
abortion you know when we brought out
the fetal chart that was actually regis
a wonderful idea yeah sometimes i'll get
lost in the weeds and
he said you know bring this out because
if if someone says
they don't have any limitations on
abortion you know show them it at four
weeks
six weeks eight weeks all the way up
until nine months and when people just
said well i don't think there should be
any limitations i go well how about
right here and i point to a baby on that
chart that's nine months or eight months
and they say no
no limitations i just say okay well
thank you very much sure and some people
may think that's cowering away
from an argument i'm sorry it's not it's
just that person has decided
that they don't they don't care whether
it's a life or not
period they want to abort there's no
there's no debate at that point as to
whether it's terminating a life
yeah right when you say i'm okay with it
up to eight months or nine months it's
not about viability it's not about it
being a life
it's not about it feeling pain it's not
about it having a it's about not about
any of those things yeah
it is about a secularist humanistic
religion where you are making sacrifices
at the altar of self and so
that's not a discussion that i want to
engage uh that's not a discussion that
i'm there to engage
same thing if we show up today and
someone says well i don't think she
should be nominated because she's racist
and i said well okay
even with that statement it's broad
enough or i will say could you would you
be willing to clarify that
she adopted black children and that's
racist
i will not continue a conversation sure
you see everything in the prism of race
i see it through the prism of of right
and wrong and
love yeah and i can't think of anything
more beautiful than a
privileged cis white female
uh and likely cis white male when you're
dealing with her husband right because
two people are adopting here uh in the
united states
taking a child from a scenario like that
and truly being colorblind i'm sorry the
fact that there is even a pretzel that
people are attempting to twist
themselves
into to argue that that is problematic
yeah uh
shows how how far around the bend many
of them have gone but that's not all
liberals and that's what changed my mind
is is hopefully we find some
you know we find some reasonable ones
who are willing to sit down and i gotta
say i'm a little nervous with this one
because they're just there really
is not much of a leg to stand on for
people arguing against acb i think
they'll probably try and pivot right
away to roe v
wade yeah and and maybe if everyone does
that we'll have to do a separate uh
roe v wade change overturn roe v wade
changed my mind but i'm hoping we can
actually talk about
acv well actually there's a question uh
here from paige says stephen do you
think
acb will attempt to overturn roe v wade
how will the democrats
then try to undermine that decision what
do you think
you think that's really on the table
under uh you know uh overturning
i don't know that it is i don't believe
that it's been with uh
with kavanaugh was uh with gorsuch um
i don't know i again and that's kind of
the complications that uh
arise when we're doing this while the
hearings are going on sure but um
i wouldn't put it past her i wouldn't
put it past her now saying there's
anything wrong with that i mean you know
you know had a real problem with roe v
wade
was rgb ruth bader ginsburg said that
she thought that was very heavy-handed
and
she was afraid did more harm than good
because roe v wade is not about uh
banning if you overturn roby wade you
don't ban abortion robbie wade is based
on the 14th amendment and this
loose sort of interpretation of privacy
rights and i don't wanna i won't get
into it too much because we'll get into
it to the
in the change my mind but um i think
that of all the justices who have been
nominated recently
uh i do believe that acb
uh there's a strong chance that she
would vote
to overturn roe v wade i don't know that
it's something
that she'll be spearheading but if it is
something that comes to the floor
uh i think she would vote for it and i'm
not and i don't think that's a bad thing
yeah well i know you do have to get
going here in a few minutes uh to get to
the change in my mind but let's uh maybe
maybe this might be a good note to end
on from scott here he says
what do you think is the number one
reason why people change their mind
politically
obviously this is the goal is to see if
we can change somebody's mind see if you
can
see if they're the type of person who
can take that but what do you think is
uh
the number one reason people do it i
would say comes from
two can i do that can i cheat and say
two absolutely i don't think scott will
be mad
scott um
truth and empathy now i want to be clear
because i know sometimes people will say
well you're not always sometimes you
come across as a dick
sure granted but um
if you look at all the actual change my
minds that have taken place where
people have changed their mind or we've
found common ground
it comes through speaking truth and that
comes through preparation and i don't
just mean preparation for these topics
but years and years of preparation
um and being empathetic to the point of
view i i can think of
uh three examples that spring to mind
right away
one was she came back on the show um the
lady at uh i can't remember the uh
school it was uh i believe in dallas uh
who had had an abortion
yeah who was pro-abortion
and i told her i said listen well i do
and she did believe in god and so we
started with that sort of premise
otherwise i wouldn't have used this
argument that's why i do believe you're
going to meet your uh
your daughter or her son i can't
remember exactly i do believe you're
going to meet your child someday
so um i think that's that's an important
thing to keep in mind
and she reached out afterward and uh she
asked to come back on the show
and she said that her mind had been
changed and that was because
it wasn't just about scoring points it
wasn't about taking a dump on our world
you know we had people who came up and
were screaming that i was a nazi and a
fascist and it's fun to make fun of
those people but that's not what we set
out to do a perfect change my mind is
where that doesn't happen and we have a
bunch of those kinds of dialogues
another one was that young lady i i'm
horrible with names but i never forget a
face
it was at ut austin where she sat down
and she talked about being from a small
town in affirmative action
and she said that she didn't believe she
would be at ut if not for affirmative
action and i walked her through i said
a second you said that you were at the
top of your class she said yes i said
you said that you didn't really have
much of a social life you didn't go out
partying that you
and i went through the list of
everything that she had told me
and i said i think that you
are supremely qualified and deserved to
be here and it's really sad to me
that you don't believe you are here at
ut austin um
that you've married it merited this seat
off of anything other than your race
and i want to tell you that's not true
well and she said
oh and a lot of people reach out to me
afterwards and she had changed her mind
there was also a black professor there
who changed his mind so
it comes from truth in empathy but it is
hard to speak
uh truth through empathy if the person
is coming in aggressive looking to score
points
that is not you know this as well that
is not what we do with change
my mind but that is what some people do
and that's why you see
a variance in the uh in the types of
discussions that take place so it really
does come through
truth that means you have to have truth
first and foremost and being empathetic
now being empathetic doesn't mean that
you agree
with all actions that are taken from
someone in other words you can be
empathetic to someone
who is living a life of sin without
necessarily praising or even condoning
the sin you can be empathetic because
and this is how christians how we all
believe we can be empathetic because we
understand that sin is bondage that sin
destroys people
and so when i hear someone talking about
abortions and how much it means to her
and how she if she couldn't have an
abortion that she wouldn't have been
able to pay for that child
i do have empathy but it's not because i
think that abortion is a brave and
beautiful thing
i have empathy because that woman
doesn't yet know that she has just
changed herself she has just placed
herself in bondage until she frees
herself from those chains
through truth so it would be truth and
empathy uh
when those two can capably intersect
they can't always but that's our job as
christians
and that's our job as critical thinkers
as um
as people who are to the right of center
yeah
good stuff yeah so we've got the change
online coming out tomorrow so you're
doing it today coming out tomorrow and
then another one
on wednesday then a big biden town hall
stream on thursday
big exciting week thank you so much for
calling in
really excited to see how this changed
my mind goes thank you for having me on
my show
i'm sorry all right cool see you later
steven and uh see you later everybody
else yeah thank you so much for joining
us a good morning mug club we will see
you tomorrow with a change in my mind
and then another one the next day and
then a stream on
thursday big week see you later
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
um
[Music]
you